i managed to say the c word in front of
150
10 year olds so that was nice wasn't it
yes
hello and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with me
chris salmon turner and me
alice win salmon oh you're not you're
not changing your name to salmon
you will not be getting any free sushi
for you and five friends in taiwan
i don't understand that's one of the new
stories this week what in taiwan a sushi
chain a restaurant a sushi restaurant
chain
ran a promotion where anyone with the
name salmon
could get a free sushi meal as much as
they wanted for them and five friends
and so over 150 people in taiwan
change their name to salvage that change
their names
wow i wonder if salmon is less of a
weird name so it's it's a character
which i think is uh spelt and i don't
know how to pronounce this guy you
um and people were changing their name
to very funny versions of it so people
would change their names like
flaming super salmon and salmon crazy
and the taiwan ministry of name changes
or whatever department does that said
this isn't funny
it's it's extra paperwork so in taiwan
there's a rule where you can change your
name i believe for free
up to three times which i like that it's
not
an even number because you think really
you should make it an even number so you
could change it then change back change
it then change back right right
the second time you've changed it you
just yeah you're stuck now yeah exactly
oh salmon now chris again oh all you can
eat beef oh i'm crisp beef well you call
chris beef now
sorry that's uh would you would you do
that
if you're in taiwan for some i mean if
you ate sushi
and salmon uh no i would not do that but
um you know kudos to those who are
willing to go through bureaucracy in
order to get free sushi
yeah that makes me think that it's
actually quite an easy process because
in the uk
i think you have to pay about 100 pounds
to change your name right so question
this was
one restaurant that did this one
restaurant chain yeah that is amazing
because the five friends thing means
that really
you just need one out of your friendship
group of six to be crazy i reckon every
group has six friends
has one person who would be willing to
change their name ours would be tom
uh he'd do it yeah so would freddie
freddie would do it
freddie would get a tattoo of a salmon
our friend freddie is wonderful and
brilliant
and when he was staying with us in
california which was one of the last
things that happened before the lockdown
for us
yeah he um he was just like oh i had
some time to kill just got a tattoo
fair play mate people get a tattoo
people are different from me
people are different that's something i
am continually reminded of
uh i think i think i would not get my
name changed
for free sushi but what did it take
for me to change my name um okay i would
change my name
if like someone became as
famous as emma watson for playing
hermione granger it was called alice win
yes i would change my name for that i
would change my name if
um the newest dictator who was trying to
conquer the world
was called alice uh what just alice
yeah like if you're okay for instance if
you're called
in the 30s like yeah i think you'd think
about changing that um
yeah chris is common enough that i don't
think i would i think adolf
well maybe adolf was much more common
until he did that and then
wouldn't you have hated it if your kid
was born in like 1933
and you were like oh this guy's gonna be
in power for a short while and you were
like i like the name adolf he's probably
gonna be fine
yeah he just he's pushed a beer hall
that was what they didn't the beer hall
put
i think that's earlier maybe earlier i
think that's in the 20s but that was the
nazis right the beer hall pushed
yes uh but 33 is when um he comes to
power
okay am i mistaken and thinking the
behold poached is this kind of like
his youthful um power grab that then
gets him thrown in prison
yes i think it was the 20s yeah oh there
you go i think i would
i would change my name maybe not for
sushi
if it was lifetime sushi definitely
would you really
i know in the uk they gave a free
playstation to someone who changed their
name to sony playstation
in france they have quite strict rules
oh yeah there's only a set
list of names yeah i think it's gotten a
little less catholic
because it sounds a wee bit racist i
think for a long time it was
only just saints names like you could it
was that was it you couldn't be
if it and the thing is in fairness there
are a lot of
saints there's so many i mean if you
find a name you'd be like oh fierica
that can't be
no there's a saint fiorica there's lots
of different things i mean there
probably isn't a saint fiodorico because
that's a name i just made up by
combining a norwegian water formation
and erica but you know why not yeah
uh yeah if you are kind of culturally
christian like that does give you a lot
of scope
for um for variety but
um yeah they're still very strict so you
can't just be like like okay if elon
musk tried to name his kid whatever the
[ __ ] his kid is named in france that
would not fly
um yeah i think oh i think they had to
change it because they weren't allowed
to name it what they wanted to there was
an aspect of it that they said we're
fine with this x and this a e and this x
you can't have that hyphen mate
i think it was something like that they
didn't change it i actually there's a
part of me that feels quite libertarian
at the notion of
the government telling me what i can
name my child i'm like excuse me if i
want to put in
uh you know an exclamation mark i'll
[ __ ] put in an exclamation mark
i um had a friend at school
um i say friend she was an enemy and her
how old
because i mean i had enemies when i was
like six or seven yeah we were probably
12.
anyway and um she had so um
her great grandparents were determined
to have a son called egbert
yeah they just thought the most
beautiful name in the world it's the
most beautiful
they were really excited about it but
unfortunately uh when they had a child
it was not a boy it was a girl
and so they were can't call it eggbert
try
forced to call the girl egg bettina
that's not good which makes me think
that the
the nursery tale the fairy tale of
thumbelina they just wanted a boy called
thumble
and they were devastated when they got a
girl we're like oh no my mother has a
pet peeve against
names that are girls names that have
obviously been just adapted from boys
names like
things like georgina but she takes it
quite far she doesn't like names like
charlotte either
because charlotte is is girly what about
alice isn't alice just girly alex
no it's not it's completely
entomological etymologically unrelated
okay well thank you for that no
etymological incest there
um i'll tell you about my week
last week we kicked off with your
stories because nothing happened for me
but
for me this week there was a big one
i've had i had three i'm very fortunate
to have
quite a few shows this week three of
them all before 5am in the morning which
was crushing
and horrible um and uh at one of those
shows i managed to say the c
word in front of 150 10 year olds
so that was nice wasn't it yes now i say
c word again not because of a problem
with it but because
youtube gets very upset if you say it
which i think is sexist it's very sexist
as we've as we've said before
i i'll explain how it happened now i
should clarify i didn't actually
say it what happened was they thought i
said it now this is for a school um
in in bahrain which is very fun to do as
an educational conference what a cool
school to put
me a freestyle rapper teaching the kids
about education
and i ended it as i always do when i
talk to kids with hey kids tell your
parents you want to be a rapper
and the kid's like yeah and the parents
are like oh we hate this person
which is awful um i was i was asked to
do a rap about
extinct animals and in that section i
said okay cool so let's be more specific
and the kids gave all these suggestions
about dodos and sabretooth tigers and
someone said
wrap about cavemen one of the people
watching said extinct animals makes me
think
of my parents very funny sick burn
um some no allowance for her but i i was
writing about cavemen
and i came up with the the excellent
lines of uh caveman language
grunt grunt me ugh like
hunt now if you're not understanding it
say it fast in your head
and it comes out in a way that i did not
intend it to
um and for the next four bars i think i
was just
madly in my head going whoops what did i
just say what did i just say
and this the show was done on a platform
where people could react with emojis
like a
facebook live or something and so people
were reacting with all these hearts and
applause when i was rapping
well that's great and then when i said
that line they reacted with wide open
mouth wow
and at the end of the show i called up
the people who booked it i was like hey
that was really great what great crowd
really enjoyed it just want to clarify
in the cave and rap and the organizer
said to me
no we know you said hunt that's fine it
didn't sound like it
when we heard it we thought what is he
doing but so they were very
understanding
and that is the you know and i told your
mother about this
and she said oh growing up i knew a boy
called michael hunt
oh that's enough that's a you would
change your name it's because in america
you would and you'd get free no you
wouldn't
um i was gonna make a very crude joke
yeah uh yeah because apparently in
america it's just such an
unused word that why would you even
think of that god americans are
such puritanical they really are
they just take it so so it just it it
just offends them so deeply and i i find
it um
oh i don't know it's just it's a real
it's a real cultural difference yeah
when you go to australia
and it's a sign of it's a sign of
endearment yeah
yeah it's great i mean i did a freestyle
rap on cameo for which you can book from
me custom freestyle apps on cameo.com
chris turner comedy so i enjoyed doing
that show the other shows were really
fun as well it's just been busy and
tiring
the thing is right so uh for listeners
you know how gross it is to wake up
before five in the morning
imagine how gross it is to wake up
before five in the morning and then go
do comedy on zoom
like improvising i mean it's it's so i
once did a show an improv show in
edinburgh that started at 10.
and i don't think a single show went
well because at 10 o'clock i am just not
actually a real person yet was that the
curious case
yes was that the show that when it was
done live in oxford frequently ballooned
into a two and a half hour show
yeah a two and a half hour improv show
two and a half hour improv murder
mystery musical it really just had legs
it would go on and on and on
it was uh fun to be in the question is
whether it was fun
to watch oh improv always strides that
line
it frequently falls off the balance it
does yeah
yeah i can't i can't wait to get back
however i i've been really enjoying
some of the zoom gigs yeah i mean i
maintain that you need to at some point
write a tattle book about zoom gigs
although i suspect then you'd lose all
your clients and maybe wait until you're
a millionaire
and then and then just burn all the
bridges yes afterwards
yeah burn it all when you know when but
i was going to say a company name then
yeah you can't um there's a there's a
character in
in a book i like which is uh called the
unbearable bassington by sarki who is
this wonderful um
sort of short story writer in uh he died
on module one
anyway um he died and his last words
were he was standing on the parapet next
to someone else and his last words were
put out that damn cigarette
because obviously if you light a
cigarette over the edge of a trench
at night it's like target practice yeah
well there was a general i think whose
last words were
shut up man they couldn't hit an
elephant at this distance oh god
generals but anyway so saki has this
character in the unbearable bassington
um who who's just everyone knows
she's writing a tell autobiography and
everyone just lives in perpetual terror
of her finally finishing it and
publishing it
and so everyone just treats her with
this like excessive respect
because she's got like the sharpest
tongue in london
and she's incredibly nasty and and like
good at just scuppering people not
scuppering
uh skewering people spearing skewering
spearing
she's just she's she's a nice piece of
work anyway but she never actually
publishes it it's just something
it's just a technique to get them to all
be nice to her yeah
that's very good that's like who is it
who we know that went to a restaurant
and then got everything free because
they had a notebook is this someone you
know
i don't know the story ah a friend
someone i know or a story i've been told
was they were at a restaurant and they
had a notebook and
like you know at the end of the meal it
must have been a comedian writing down
jokes the
manager comes up and goes compliments of
the house because they thought they were
a
reviewer
and i've tried that and it's never
worked no
mainly because i'm just drawing big
penises and uh you know they can see
in um scott fitzgerald's this side of
paradise there's this line that's his
first novel
uh there's this section where he and his
friends at university
all go off on this like amazing romp
and uh and they're trying to get the
word romp twat's on a rom
they are [ __ ] and they they're like
rich [ __ ] and they go
to this fancy restaurant and they just
order everything
and then uh when the waiter brings the
bill at the end
the guy he brings it to just kind of
frowns
and gives it back to the waiter and goes
evidently there's been a mistake
and then they all walk out and it takes
a long time for the waiter to because
because the way he says it makes it
sound as if like his dad owns the
restaurant or something
and so the waiter's just like oh well i
guess i guess they eat for i don't know
uh and so then they just drive away
another pay
i remember being maybe six it was either
six
or 10 or 11 because i was at disneyland
paris in my family and i went there
on my sixth birthday and then on my
sister's maybe sixth birthday or a
couple of years after
and i remember it was so exciting
because i didn't know we were going and
a surprise trip to disneyland no that's
a great thing
is incredible so i remember vaguely
being woken up by my parents
and told come on christopher and this is
like four in the morning
i'm like what what do i have to do a
zoom gig
like come on and then they just take me
there
and i'm at disneyland paris they're good
at keeping a secret i'm bad at keeping
secrets remember we
i kept a secret holiday from you until
we were on the plane and i was like no
you never been to norway and it was on
the train it was on the train to the
airport you kept it so secret
and you were like i'm taking you
somewhere and then yeah you told me in
the last minute
i mean it was you you kept it secret for
a few weeks yeah that was pretty that's
pretty impressive
i should also say um the thing about
zoom gigs some of them being fun
doing i did a zoom gig for you know a
special audience of people who
like what i do and it's signed up for
zoom gigs if you want to come to those
uh go to the link list in the
description it was really fun it was
really enjoyable we're doing one
uh at the end of this week if you're
listening to this although it's probably
full up
anyway sign up and come along go on
about disneyland
so we're in we're in disneyland and
we're in a restaurant and this is maybe
a couple days into the holiday
and they just keep my parents keep
asking for the bill and no one brings
the bill and it was maybe 20 minutes
and they go right we're leaving and i
was appalled and horrified
you can't you have to pay what mickey
mouse needs some money
uh and they went no we've given them 20
minutes to win the bill which is a fair
amount of time to bring the bill
and so they just they just walked out
and that was the the first time i
realized my parents were criminals
i hope they're listening in their jail
cells imagine imagine stealing
money from the poor underdog corporation
that is disney
i my brother has this theory and i i
think he's it's hard to disprove
he says he says that there is not anyone
in the last like 100 years who has had a
bigger cultural
impact than walt disney and i
i have tried to think of someone and i i
think it's pretty tricky
because it's global and it affects all
children yeah for
100 years i think i think that's fair i
mean also we
you know we discussed this with living
celebrities when we ate
a meal in the same restaurant next to
steven spielberg yeah you were very
excited about that
steven spielberg yeah what's wrong with
you disgusting behavior
we've had an argument over is that the
most famous person
the most influential person in the world
who's alive who's alive and then we
found a forbes article
where they'd done a survey a couple of
years before of asking people all over
the world
here's a list of people tick the ones
that have influenced your life
and steven spielberg came out on top
with just over 50 percent of people
saying yes
and if you think about it he really does
with his movies over the decades he
really has you know
loads of people must love it you know
they must have one of those movies
or whatever if you think about the fact
that schindler's list and jurassic park
came out in the same year that is insane
and just think of the mash-up of that as
well would you like some news
i'd love some news i'm leaving you oh
god not
[Music]
gotta wait until july i thought i think
july i think yeah that's when we have to
send in more of our love letters to be
approved that we are actually a couple
uh we started talking about salmon
let's talk about meat or the lack of it
did you did you uh follow
colorado's don't eat meat policy
yesterday no
you didn't what out of one day or the
rest of your life wait
sorry vegetarian i thought you meant
like follow along in the news okay yes i
am vegetarian so i did not eat anything
so yesterday was the
meat meat off the menu day um and it was
governor
jared polis of colorado who said hey
let's all you know
try and not eat meat yesterday and uh
just like once
a new weekly no no it's just one one day
a year let's be mindful
obviously no one told the governor of
nebraska that because he then launched a
blistering attack on jared polis saying
this would destroy our way of life
saturday
is meat on the menu day everyone eat
more meat than usual sound nebraska is a
beef producing steak
i do think saturday's a weird day to do
your not meat eating like you're spo
like
christianity wise you're supposed to not
eat meat on fridays that's where your
fish and chips on fridays in britain
no really if friday is fish day
oh yeah because jesus dies on a friday
friday was pizza day in my family
not fish pizza because my dad used to
change his name for salmon sounds as if
your family did not have enough
uh respect heathens yeah um i just
really love that
a guy being like hey one day a year it's
not like you know hey international
women's day
no man it is such an
underwhelming ask like one day please
can we just not eat meat just for just
one more just immediately just like hair
triggered because it was like which will
destroy our economy but you know
that i mean that's because clearly the
governor senator of the governor of
nebraska is
you know you know that's what gets his
votes no no but i just think i just
think that
what what it means when people react
that strongly
to such a small thing is that they feel
as if they're constantly
on the verge of losing something that's
important to them okay
yeah i can't imagine that i love meat
and you know i'm doing a vegan comedy
show
in april and the organizer said hey if
you just don't rap about how you eat
meat which when people tell me not to
rap about a thing
it makes it harder because then it's in
my head the whole time like at this gig
in bahrain in the warm-up i'd done a
wrap and someone had suggested sausage i
write about sausage and then
the person doing the text said you
probably shouldn't wrap back that
because pork is haram
which means forbidden and probably not
frank's that right um
and then in the show someone asked me to
wrap up pineapple on pizza
and i did mention hawaiian pizzas but uh
you know i think i got away with it
and yeah i i can't i can't fathom being
angered by that but i guess that just
makes me a better person
and therefore i should be the governor
of nebraska although really no i should
be angered by it if i want to be the
governor of nebraska
um i think that uh the governor of
nebraska probably feels as if
uh all of the things that make his life
uh recognizable are currently being
questioned and that's
that's nerve-wracking and scary aren't
you nice to empathize with the governor
of nebraska
the next news story is that he is uh
abducted 50 children
and force-fed them burgers i think that
his reaction is
is uh silly and immature and um shows a
lack of
thoughtfulness but i also think that um
i think that
it's very easy on the left to feel just
like absolutely flummoxed
by the right wing and i think i'm sure
it's vice versa
yes and i just think that i think that
kind of bewilderment is unhelpful and i
think if you try and
actually understand like the fear that
is coming from the opposite side
that is helpful in at least being able
to not just be
just baffled what
i liked the most was that in his
statement he said
beef is part of a healthy diet and the
thing is i don't think anyone can argue
that red meat is part of a healthy diet
maybe i don't i'm not in the past our
ancestors bred and hunted cows i'm not
sure they did mate not sure they did i
think they just so i've talked to you
about this before
but i read a lot of old literature and
really you've never brought that up
before
i've spent this whole week being like
chris was the gawain and the green
knights story
really very boring and chris keeps being
like no
and i'm like wait but but was it
actually
desperately boring and chris is like no
of course
not anyway but um what i'm saying is uh
you you come across in these like you
know victorian
novels um descriptions of what people
eat
and uh it really hammers home that they
ate differently like um
and i know that so i'm reading david
cockfield at the moment and um this is
you know when he's suffering and he's
working in a factory and he's a child
and like
the whole point is that he's not getting
enough food but the only thing he eats
all day
is bread and beer
so he's he's like eight and all he eats
all day is bread and beer
every day sounds like an absolute party
it sounds like carbs on carbs on carbs
unhealthy that is and then the other
thing that um this made me think of was
when i was reading siegfried soon's um
sort of autobiographical um war novels
ding second mention of the war carry on
did i mention the war already world war
one early on yeah with something i can't
even help it
okay so um in in one of these books he's
talking about how
he's about to go hunting for a whole day
so he needs to have a really healthy
breakfast and really
gear up because he's not gonna have
anything to eat until crumpets at five
o'clock
and he and that's in 12 hours crumpets
at five o'clock crumpets are a breakfast
food
uh no they're teaching food for american
listeners
i cannot describe what a crumpet is you
just have to see one yourself
um they they are a tea time food but
anyway um the point
is that to have this bolstering all day
breakfast
sits down and he eats eggs
just eggs no mention of how many eggs
i feel like if that's all you're going
to eat until five whilst you do
quite hard exercise you've got to eat
like a minimum of
six eggs oh yeah no it's half a dozen
eggs mint that's a lot of eggs because
you don't even have soldiers with them
nothing it's just for american listeners
describe give me it describe me it's
just uh it's toast cut up and slices
with butter on it and you dip it into
the egg
yeah you take the chop the top off and
you dip it in the soft boiled yolk do
you know what um roald dahl's
one-armed father said was the one thing
he missed about having two arms
he couldn't chop the top of an egg yeah
my gosh that's great
the way you said that made me think did
rodney have two fathers only one of whom
had one off
yeah he's actually super really um
really liberal hated the jews loved
auntie seymour
uh pro lgbt um that was our
meet our meat section and i didn't even
do a pun about how the governor of
nebraska had beef with jared polis
so let me just pop that in there did you
ever do any online dating
you know perfectly well i didn't i know
but i didn't want to lead in by going
my wife never dated online on like all
you losers
you know i'm trying to provide a nice
segue uh i didn't we i don't think
either of us ever did in the online
dating yeah because
we started going out in 2013 and i think
tinder was
starting it was a new thing i i used to
sate my tinder desire
by tindering for my female friends yes
so i would
dredge through all the scum on tinder
but you know swiping what i thought then
having funny conversations with them
catfishing them eventually
you were um what's it is it is it cyrano
de bergerac
people say that all the time and i do
not know if there is a person or a
french aperitif
so sereno de berge vasirac
he's not very handsome and the point is
that uh his friend is in love with a
girl
and so but his friend's like not very
good at expressing himself so cyrano
writes
letters for the friend or like i think
there's a scene with a friend
um is shout is like trying to seduce the
woman she's on her balcony he's standing
sereno is hiding in the bushes and like
whispering to the
very handsome friend what to say um so
yeah god i wonder who wrote that
anyway so you'll see you serenade a
bunch of act on tinder
yeah i did um had some success um
and what i'm getting to is that that
tinder
always seemed a bit weird that
it was just you had to trust that that
was what the person said they were right
often
people would lie about things um and
recently there was a study where they
found
a surprising amount of people with
convictions for
sexual offenses and other violent crimes
on these match sites and so match which
is the company that owned tinder and
hinge and plenty of fish and all these
other things
they've now agreed to introduce
background checks wait but hang on hang
on hang on okay
the way that people used to like hook up
before tinder was you'd go clubbing and
you'd be like that guy's hot and then
you go home with him
right yeah that you would also be likely
to hook up but don't you feel that with
the advance of technology
that should be a thing that therefore
you can get rid of like oh cool the fact
that we're doing this on a phone means
they can be pre-vetted
i i immediately get some alarm bells
somehow
yeah i know you mean so they did point
out they were like look the only
convictions
so basically when you sign up it's gonna
cross-reference your phone and email
your name with a database provided by a
company that they also have a stake in
um doesn't that are you going to do a
pun about staking being a beef thing no
i was not going to make it it wouldn't
happen in colorado
i was just gonna i don't know i just um
as i said a long belt that just makes
you feel i know what you mean but those
they've said look these are for
restraining orders
uh you know domestic violence assault
convictions sexual convictions
they're not going to do drug offences
and they've said look there's no
correlation between
uh sexual assault and drug use and then
they're not going to traffic offences
now i get it i get that it feels weird
however no i mean i i see
hey here is the thing that will make you
safer obviously there's points where
you're like
oh when is that control but also hey
wouldn't it be nice for people to be
safe i think when you list the things
that they're going to be scanning for
that makes me feel a little bit better
about it
um because yeah those all seem fairly
relevant to
people who are trying to date so i'm i'm
imagining now that you've got a tinder
profile but it just says
wait did you find out but it just says
like on your so it's like hi
i'm chad here's my you know really hot
abs and also
i sexually assaulted eight women in
2016.
busy year for chad um is that what it's
like like is it gonna sell my profile or
is it just gonna be like you can't have
tinder
i think it i don't think if someone's
done the time
then i don't think they can not let them
do it right because we assume that
prison time is well known voting don't
we so
well like this is i guess yeah i'm
thinking of the uk more than
okay yeah more than america wait so can
prisoners vote after they get out of the
prison in the uk i believe so let's
check that fun fact i've just learned by
looking that up
you can vote if you've served your
sentence in the uk and
britain is the only country in the
european union this is a slightly old
article
that banned prisoners while they were in
prison from voting and the european
court and human rights said that is a
violation of civil liberties and you
can't do that
and they should have been allowed to
vote um therefore america which is the
place where if you're a convicted felon
you lose your right to vote forever in
many states
um or at least for some period of time
that is out of step with everyone else
just as britain is out of step with the
rest of the uk and
the rest of the eu and not letting them
vote when they're in the prison
right right well that uh makes sense
so in summary i think you probably can
still have a tinder account
or just move over to bumble they're not
doing background checks
uh i think probably everyone will start
doing back i mean to be fair
when i say i have alarm bells i don't
have alarm bells about like uber drivers
having background checks and actually
it's kind of the same isn't it
so i guess that makes sense yeah the the
main story this week uh is a
again a sad sad one um in atlanta
there was a murders
shootings um at spas specifically
uh as as people were seen from protests
this week targeted at asian americans
and asian people
uh six people of asian descent killed
out of eight people killed total
um and a lot of the discussion has
revolved around the news coverage of
this
where once again it's a white man
doing a crime and people saying no this
isn't
racially motivated this isn't terrorism
this is this man like one of the
the sheriffs i think who gave a news
conference said
uh he had a bad day and this is what he
did what
you're like mate come on i've had bad
days before
we need media training for these these
little deputies the the person who did
it has contended that they
had have a sex addiction yes so did
russell brand
yeah as far as we know he just dumped
katy perry before she was about to go on
stage
yes exactly by text it looked like in
that documentary okay
uh that's really rubbish and i don't
understand why
i mean maybe this is simplistic but like
it's that what's that saying of like if
it sounds like a horse and looks like a
horse it's probably a horse not a zebra
i think that is the saying okay never
really used it i
there are sayings i've never used i
think about that saying a lot and i
really think about i was thinking about
it with reference to like meghan markle
as well
because um there were people online
being saying she looks like a horse
that's horrendously effective
you're thinking of zara phillips mate uh
don't call any women hey look
just don't don't get don't do it oh [ __ ]
now i can't get a tinder account
um so i was thinking about it with with
reference to
megan because i think quite a few people
were like okay but the reason the
british press was nasty to her was not
because she was black
and it's like okay what what else is the
reason like
that does seem like the principal most
obvious reason
that could be a problem i think the
horse saying is essentially occam's
razor but done in a more equine way
tell me alchemist ochem's razor as far
as i'm aware is the
philosophical concept that uh well the
simplest explanation is probably correct
right and i think if you've got a guy
who's just gone
and murdered six asian americans
specifically driven to
three asian spas
that yeah i think it's not unreasonable
to assume that that's
racially you know motivated i think it's
i think you have to be contorting
yourself to try and argue that it's not
yeah um georgia so what's interesting is
whether this will be tried he's been
charged with the murders and he's
confessed to the murders
uh whether he'll be charged under a new
racial hatred law which georgia didn't
have until the
killing of ahmed arbury who was the man
who was jogging and was
driven after and killed by white men um
and
these laws mean that if you
commit a crime based on pretty much any
type of
distinguishing feature your nationality
your race your religion your color
all these things your sexual orientation
it then carries a stiffer penalty
um i think with that would be similar to
you know
different degrees of murder being like a
crime of passion
is more leniently treated often than
premeditated murder yeah because
yeah it kind of should be that makes
sense
i think it's sort of it's less abhorrent
i mean obviously you know nothing
but um yeah it's it's less disgusting
yeah
um a lot of the conversation is rolled
around the fetish like the fetishization
of
uh asian specifically asian women right
because they're often kind of
seen as as um
explicitly stacked like just like sexual
beings uh
it is weird and i think it probably
comes from like
victorians very [ __ ] up relationship
with sex
the way um white people just
have put together these assumptions
about
other races um and like for instance
there's
a you know a long and storied history of
white people thinking of
uh africans as being like hypersexual
and um yeah of of
asian women in particular as being kind
of hypersexual and it's it's sort of
straight i think it comes from the fact
partly that they were so busy making
their own women completely
desexualized right um because in the
victorian era everyone was very very
puritanical and there's
i don't know if this is apocryphal but
like the the rumor is that like
they used to cover up like piano legs
and piano tables and kate
and and just table legs in case they
made you think of a woman's legs and
then you would just oh my god
go crazy um so when i see an ankle
but you know it it's it was it was
interesting to me when i was um
i read uncle tom's cabin shortly after i
had just read uh or reread
um north and south and they are written
within like five years of each other
north and south is by elizabeth gaskell
and it is about um
like a young woman in uh basically
pseudo manchester in the 1840s
and in so in the 1840s
in britain if a young woman um
a young middle-class woman went to a
train station with her brother and
people didn't know that that was her
brother and thought that was a man that
could ruin her reputation
but at the same time in america
they are having slave auctions where
like 15 year old girls are being sold
explicitly to be sex slaves so there's
these two things happening at once in
the 1800s
there is this um excessive purity
of white women and then excessive
sexualization of women of color
and i think that we still have hangovers
from that um in a big way i mean i'm
sure it's also you know more complicated
and i'm sure uh lots of new things were
added
um to that dynamic in the 19th the 20th
century but
yeah i think this is something that
women of color suffer with a lot
right is this their sexuality being
taken out of their hands
yeah there was a tweet from uh someone
an asian woman asian-american woman
saying
that they'd hooked up with someone after
a concert in the bathroom
and then a cop stopped them when they
came at the stall and was like
oh i need to see your immigration status
gross yeah
um in uh in my college st hughes college
that used to be an
all-female college until the 90s and
if you had a male
friend come to stay if this is
me i don't know what year this stopped
but this must have been in the 60s or
70s at least
if you had a male friend round you had
to have your bed you had to drag your
mattress
out of your dorm room to show that you
weren't having sex
now one have you ever heard of the floor
guys
floor sex get those carpet burns
um and i learned this because i i did
fundraising for my college and i called
up old students
uh alumni is meant to call them not old
students but old students
and i was like hey so oh you know the
college
how was it in your day you want to kind
of foster a connection before you say
now give us some money for some library
books
and this woman said well we had this
rule and uh when my brother came to stay
he just came to see me for the day and
uh one of the the supervisors came and
said why is your mattress i'm not
outside the room and she goes
because this is my brother and the guys
i get that mattress outside now
which is preposterous i still remember
being dreadfully insulted when i went to
a male friend's
bedroom in my first year of university
and we were just he was an old friend
and we were just hanging out friend you
mean
and we we hung out until quite late um
and then
i wanted to leave the college but the
college doors have been locked for the
night
and so i had to go to the porter and get
the porter to unlock the doors for me
and the porter was like next time get
your little friend
to put his trousers back on and walk you
out and i was like
well [ __ ] you wow that's worse than
pembroke college which was known for
being a very uh
stingy colleague he had no money it was
fun what was it
broke pembroke they they used to find
their students for everything i remember
being at a friend's house
at pembroke and we hadn't signed
in because we'd gone there at 6 00 p.m
to have some beers in the college bar so
like why would you
what sign in um next you're gonna want
background checks
and then uh we left it like one in the
morning after having some booze and the
doors were locked and the guy
goes oh so you weren't signed in were
you
well that's a 150 pound fine for your
friend there isn't it and it's like
i beg your pardon hey what because you
have to open the door with your key
absolute trash pembroke you can bug her
off
yeah some of those colleges are um so
like excite some of those college
porters are very i mean look
there are some college porters who are
fantastic most of them are i would go
through
these i've only had a few bad
experiences but yeah
some of them i just get really excited
about the power um
college porters for people who don't
know are a group of guys who
sit at the porter's lodge which is
actually the entrance okay
yeah i mean my college all all men i
think you can be a female porter i'm
sure you can um
portorette i believe they're called
porterina if you wanted
they chill out in the porter's lodge
they you know give you your mail
they let you in they'll like open up
your rooms if you've forgotten your keys
they come to your room if a fire alarm
goes off they make the college in my
college they were lovely and it wasn't
they yeah they were so um because they
would they were the ones who would see
you like coming home
crying from the club you know at three
in the morning by yourself and they
would
make a witty quick like don't you have
an essay due tomorrow shut up
because yeah no how do you think the
world's gonna end alice when
not with a bang but with a whimper oh
very good who said that diaz elliott
oh in the war no um i don't think he
fought on the wall
bloody american what he never knew that
yeah
knew that his name is an anagram of
toilets didn't know that he was american
absolutely
this is like robert frost being
californian edward gorey being american
what
disgusting tell me how the world's gonna
end uh in 2045 because we can't have
kids anymore
yes you have been talking about this a
lot because i'm worried about it
so they've done studies and these pfas
and
pharlates and all these plastics that
are in everything plastics everywhere
did you know that a man the average man
now
has half the sperm count of his
grandfather i mean his grandfather from
back then not his current grandfather
because that would be very upsetting um
and the average
woman in her 20s is now as uh fertile as
her grandmother was when she was 35.
yeah no it's not great and it's funny
because
um we've all been worried about
overpopulation and now actually
it's turning into children of men yeah
so yeah exactly which is
absolutely brilliant so good um so yeah
some scientists have said they've done
some studies
and it is such a big deal they've looked
at the declining growth rate and they've
just charted it saying
it's not like oh if this carries on
there'll be no kids by 2045.
obviously that wouldn't happen because
it would slow down and they're like no
that
actually looks like it might happen
we're not going to have children
they've done studies these these
chemicals in decreased
gonad size so you're bored the official
words yes because going out to apply to
women and men
women have gone ads men have gonads what
the hell you can only kick a man in the
nads
you can't kill what's a gonad the the
the sex producing organs oh my god
so like overreason testies are going out
no well yeah how would you sounds very
undignified
go on go go an add-on um they
yeah they shrink penis size apparently
penis sizes and animals have been
getting smaller because of these
plastics therefore
penis size and men and we are becoming
uh
just infertile so okay
something i think about is that we spend
a lot of time being like lol the
victorians had lead pipes
and i'm like yeah we
we have cancer in everything we use at
all times
whenever i move to california they have
a thing called proposition 65 which
means that on pretty much everything
there has to be a warning that says this
contains chemicals known to cause harm
to the state of california
as in known to the state of california
to cause harm they're not worried about
harming the state of california
and when i moved i thought oh it's a bit
overkill and then you realize wait a
minute
everything gives you cancer literally
and i think i think we often think to
ourselves like come on everything you
get
water gives you cancer you can't even
worry about it and it's like
yeah but um a lot of things give you
much more cancer and those are the
things that we buy and
use every day all the time it really
reminds me of like how women in the
renaissance would just put arsenic on
their faces to make them look whiter
and it's like yeah i think we're doing a
lot of things that are that equivalent
yeah i mean it's that thing of it's
foolish
to look back at people from the past go
leeches
what idiots they use they drilled holes
in people's head to treponate them
you're like well well and you think
we've got everything perfect now you
fool
yeah no although i will say our medicine
is
pretty [ __ ] great compared to most
people it's great
yeah but still people in the future will
look back at us and go heathens
that's very true they gave them
artificial legs they didn't just regrow
a leg
yeah there's gonna be so many things
like that that's the cool thing about
getting older i reckon
is that by the time you're like 70
you'll be able to like know
what things you like that
you thought were true in your 20s
actually turned out to be false
don't think you understand the
stubbornness of old people can they
still believe
no no for instance when my mother was in
school they didn't know about
continental drift
and she was like i wonder how this
happened and then by the time she was
older they discovered it like that's
cool that's pretty cool
i forgot if it's hard to figure out
about continental drift
oh yeah well of course once someone's
come up with the the theory you're like
i think
i would have come up with it it's like
me when i came up with communism
independently
really how did this happen how old were
you i was probably you know ten i was
like you just you just
you know dressed up in a uniform put on
a mustache and we're like
look if we just have a great leap
forward
very good very good um
opposite of communism mr trump uh
there's a waxwork of him
in a museum in texas it's not on display
this take off display do you think
that's because texas have suddenly
fallen i love mr trump
no why don't you took off display uh
because people kept stealing him
no people kept punching him oh
do you remember that picture of him
crying when he when he lost the election
yeah it was just he just looked so sad
that's the whole
thought he just looked so sad well that
wasn't what they based the wax work on
um
someone asked them when are you going to
put it back out and they said i guess
probably
once we've got a wax work of biden
because then they can have that and then
it you know it's fair you can punch the
one you want
maybe that should be like a voting
system i do you know because the thing
about wax works is you got from you take
a photo with them and you're like hey
look it's me with george clooney
but i don't know i think that punch
having a what's what you can punch i
don't know i think that's quite fun
i think they're quite expensive to make
is the problem no it's wax made go
straight back i
i think it's i think it's not easy to
make them yeah i mean to be honest if
you see all those pictures of bad wax
work museums
uh they are pretty bad is there a paris
hilton horror film
there is house of wax have we seen that
no i think i saw it once
late night on in a hotel television and
it was very good
really really excellent i think watching
a film late night in a hotel is really
the best way to judge its quality
real get that cinematic experience so uh
yeah
stop punching wax works maybe people in
texas believe in voodoo dolls
yeah like yeah this is gonna hurt him i
mean it would hurt his feelings if he
found out
it would yeah because he's got tiny
hands he can't punch back i
he just i never liked that the tiny
hands joke i just think he wouldn't
it's the kind of thing that he takes
very personally isn't it what that
arrogant egotistical narcissist takes
things about his appearance very
personally we're on to breaking news
breaking news breaking news put on your
shoes is breaking news it's news that
has happened today
aka breaking news it's not news
that is slowing down by breaking did you
realize that did you know that it means
it's news it's just breaking not news
that is slowing down
i don't want anyone listening to get
confused and think that breaking news is
news that is slowing down now it's news
it just broke it's gonna be to explain
this
yeah no it's very important for people
to understand this uh so
breaking news said that way more times
than i need to
breaking news qantas the the head of
qantas the australian airline
has said that um you can have to be
vaccinated to
to travel to australia on their airline
um and he said that many governments are
in
conversations at the moment of making
that uh prerequisite for travel
and even if the government says no as an
airline head he's
his responsibility to keep his passenger
safety now if you think about airlines
their number one responsibility is
passenger safety right pontus is the one
that's never had a crash right
i believe so yeah it was true in the 70s
yeah okay cool
um so yeah uh
i mean i mentioned this to you earlier
today um i managed to bring this up you
know
obviously there's a huge ethical debate
around whether this should be the case
um right because some people can't get
vacancies some people can't get
vaccinated and
also at the moment teenagers can't get
vaccinated so
sorry that you a can't have a proper
college experience and b
have to stay in your country teenagers
obviously there's
a huge debate that could be had around
this but really only broad because you
you gave me such a lovely analogy well i
love it
i love long-haul slides i miss them like
crazy i
just got on a plane and just flew around
just to land back
people did that flights to nowhere a few
months after the pandemic broke oh yeah
they did didn't they
just to get on a plane which you would
think would break quarantine rules
because you'd have
no you're not leaving the country are
you no but you're getting a bunch of
people on a plane
okay yeah well that's true um anyway but
uh yeah my analogy was so
you know you get you get on the plane
and everything is lovely and there's
this you know blinky blanca music and
you know these sort of flight attendants
all look incredibly
you know well put together and they're
like thank you for flying ba and you're
like oh what a wonderful experience
and then you sit down and there's like a
folded blanket and then by the time you
leave
everyone is just disgusting and it
reminds me of how
like when you go clubbing you arrive at
the club
and you're like i look great you've
spent ages on your makeup you're wearing
a cute outfit
you look hot and then that's just the
men
and then when the lights come up at the
end and you look around and it's just
horrible and everyone looks hot like
just
just appalling and i think that's what
it's like at the end of a flight
i agree i thought it was such a good
analogy you made me think of the los
camposinas song
you me dancing where it has the line
isn't it weird that in supermarkets they
turn their lights off when they want you
to go home but at discounts they turn
the lights on
and i was like oh yeah that feels
profound for two seconds and then you're
like wait what
it's yeah i mean you say you look great
when you go clubbing
uh one of my clubbing experiences in the
uk was uh
to be clear i don't think i've gone
clubbing since i was about 15.
all right calm down mate i was clubbing
before it was legal yeah
um i i arrived at a club in oxford
covered in blood and didn't realize
until the next day and it was because i
had taken a bottle of beer to drink on
the way and i brought taken another one
and i tried to pop the top off on a
fence railing and it wouldn't pop off so
i
just smashed the neck of the bottle off
and just drank from it very hard and
obviously that cut open my
lip uh and then i bled all down my face
and i still got let in the club
with the bleeding lip i didn't
smashed realize really it was just that
tells you how handsome i was and how
desirable
they were to have me in their club um
and yeah dancer on night and then the
next stage going i was like why haven't
i got a face covered in blood why did no
one tell me
one because my friends are absolutely
legends and you wouldn't you know you
don't tell that that's great
um but yeah they were fine so i mean i
obviously looked better when i went in
when i went out because when i went in i
was just producing blood when i went out
i was
covered in the blood yeah that is
it's funny how sometimes when you're
injured you don't notice like the two
people i know have been stabbed and
didn't notice for ages
what i've told you this oh you have but
don't assume that everyone here
listening knows oh yeah alice knows two
people have been stabbed but didn't
notice
right so i'll i'll just tell one of the
staffing stories keep the other one keep
your tinder dry
yeah but um i was doing this i was doing
a uh
an improv class in la which is a
horrible thing to do don't do it
but um so uh one of the
things that you do in these improv
classes give monologues based off a
suggestion and then people do scenes
from that monologue
and there was this girl in our group who
was very very quiet
and sort of too intense to be funny
um very beautiful in a very much like
2017 instagram way
and she always wore like sky-high heels
and just like it seemed like she'd walk
straight off at influenza
profile and so she's a bit of a mystery
and then she gets up to do a monologue
once and i don't remember what the
suggestion was it was something like
hotel
right and she comes forward and she's
like
um well a little while ago i was
in venice italy and um
near venice italy and maestra and i was
walking at night to my hotel in the rain
with my suitcase
and you know i always wear heels so i
was sort of stumbling along
through the cobbles and this man came up
to me in the dark
and just kind of touched me and i was
like
get away so he left and i was just a
little
confused by what had happened and so i
went
to my hotel and when i got there the
hotel man
was just like what happened to you and i
was like
nothing and he was like you have been
stabbed
and i looked down and there was a knife
in my stomach
and we were like excuse me what and then
she was like
that's my monologue and then we had to
do scenes basis for an improv scene
really but like yeah i think this is a
real thing
uh and i i remember reading the empress
[ __ ] also when she was stabbed um she
didn't notice until she got home and
took off her corset
i think you don't always notice it's in
sherlock holmes in it they uh
kill a guy by putting he has a needle in
his ability
he takes it off that he dies so yeah i
can understand that
wow i love your instagram influencer
voice it's very good thanks
no genuine emotion behind it just dead
behind the eyes getting those
endorsements
do you feel anything i was quite fond of
that girl in the end she was an amazing
story she was also secretly a circus
acrobat i don't know where she had come
from
wow that's pretty impressive oh well
that's that's the end of the news
um so alice what would you like to tell
us about this week is it part two of
gwen and the green knight
you wish uh so i just read this story
and i thought it was pretty good
it's from uh marie de france's lay
um so she was you know hawaiian she's a
medieval writer i was
reading her stories and there's one
called biscolar
yeah that's not a word is it bisclavret
bisclaveret
okay this cleverett and i just want to
start by just reading you just a section
from the intro
um can it be a french accent please
no please in days gone by
one could hear tell and indeed it is
often used to happen
that many men turned into werewolves and
went to live in the woods
a werewolf is a ferocious beast with
which when possessed by this madness the
vow is men
causes great damage and dwells in vast
forests
i love it so that's the kind of
background on
biscler bisclervret blah blah blah
biscuit uh so in brittany there's this
baron who's a very good baron called
this cleverett
and it's a good job it's not a vital
part of the story it's not the main
character it's not the title of the
story or anything
uh yeah and he he is married to this um
beautiful woman
and everything seemed to be going pretty
well for him and uh
his marriage was very happy however
every week
he went missing for three days and uh
she really missed him and worried about
him when he was gone so finally one day
she um she just said please tell me
where you go i i
beg that you tell me if you don't tell
me i'm worried i will die
and he was like well i don't want you to
die but please don't ask me to tell you
and she says i
beg of you to tell me so he says all
right fine
three days a week i turn into a wolf
what
would you thought that would happen but
also that's not like a normal werewolf
lore right it's supposed to be at the
full moon not three days a week that's a
lot of
kills that's too much where willfully i
think so um
and she's like uh well that that scares
me and he goes no don't worry it's fine
uh and then she who's this we're talking
about again this is
this club this club
um then she asks this question which i
don't know why it occurs to him she goes
okay wait hang on so when you turn
what happens to your clothes are you
naked or do you turn into a wolf in your
clothes and then turn back out
in your clothes well that's it like the
incredible hulk right he turns into the
hulk but somehow his
trousers will stay home yeah but so so
that's the kind of question you expect
to see on like a reddit forum
not in like a medieval wife's mouth but
i think
the layers of mario de france were the
reddit of their time
anyway so she's like yeah so what
happens to your clothes and he goes
don't ask me that and she says well i
really need to know and he says well
my clothes i i take them all off and i
put them in a special chapel
and then i turn into a wolf and if
anything were to happen to my clothes
i would have to stay a wolf forever what
yeah it's like when someone goes
swimming in a teen movie and they run
away with their clothes and they have to
get out oh god
right right so it's a kind of fatal flaw
of werewolf fism
in uh the middle ages but there you go
so um
after she hears about this she is kind
of disgusted by her husband and she no
longer wants to be a good wife to him
and there was a night who was madly in
love with her when she was younger who
she always kind of ignored
and so she sends for him and she says i
will give you my love and i will give
you my body if you
take care of my husband for me and take
care of my husband
and then like look after you yeah it's
about male friendship anyway so he goes
he goes to the chapel well surely first
he would have said well who is your
husband and she would have said
this gloverette okay cool this cleverett
yeah bisclevret
disclaimer anyway uh so
so he goes and takes away the clothes
and the husband
because he's been disappearing for three
days a week no one thinks that much of
it at first when he doesn't return
but after a while people just assume he
must be dead
and so um the the lady is announced to
be a widow and she remarries the man
who was in love with her who basically
um took away her
husband's wolf clothes so for a while
they live together everything is fine
now remember that this baron had been
very loyal to his king
and one day the king is hunting in the
forest and suddenly
this um you know his men are hunting
this wolf and the wolf comes out
and starts being like very friendly and
dog-ish to the king
and the king's like hang on this wolf
has supernaturally intelligent abilities
like a human
i think something's fishy here tell that
that's why they're chosen to be the king
right yeah they've got yeah they've got
a really good eye for
wolves with human characteristics and so
they take this wolf back
to um the palace and uh he's
just like he becomes everyone's best
friend he sleeps in the same bedroom as
the king
he's so loyal and faithful to the king
he's gentle as a lamb he never hurts
anyone
but one day the king hosts a tournament
and um
the knight who married the wife shows up
at the tournament and the second that
the wolf sees him the wolf attacks him
and um everyone is like well hang on
this wolf is usually very well behaved i
suspect that the knight has done
something wrong
which is the same approach that dog
owners always [ __ ] take and it drives
me mad
yeah people are like oh my dog doesn't
like you like
i think there's something about your
moral character that
doesn't say he's a really good judge of
character i'm
yeah hmm i'm not sure i want you to
teach my children absolutely
and it's just like your dog's a menace
that's a really good paul f tompkins
[ __ ] i remember this [ __ ] he's
fine he's trying to murder me
like that a dog going run run run bro
he's like if that was your
best friend literally your best friend
not a dog but a person
and he ran at me going right you
wouldn't say that
yeah it's very true i also read
somewhere in like a book about
um about like fear that the reason that
dogs often react badly to people that
you also don't like
is that what what's actually happening
is your dog is hypersensitive to your
fear tells you and so if you have a bad
vibe from a person your dog is
also like could have a bathroom so um he
leaves and everyone's like well
we can't blame the dog for that because
that was um
probably the night's fault um and then
they have this big
feast with all the wives of the knights
and biscuits thank you
thank you um his wife
is there and the second he sees her the
wolf attacks her and
bites off her nose
[Music]
yes and instead of being like holy [ __ ]
this wolf just bit off a woman's face
the king is like what did that woman do
to that wolf
which is fair in this context she did um
and so they
they decide that they need to find out
what the woman did to the wolf so they
take her into the dungeons and they
torture her until she confesses
uh in great agony to the the trick she
played on him
and um so then they go back and find the
clothes
that apparently her night hadn't
destroyed but just put somewhere else
and um give the clothes back to the wolf
but the wolf won't turn back and
everyone's like oh did we make a mistake
um until someone points out that the
wolf is probably just quite body shy
and so then everyone leaves the room and
then the wolf turns back into biscuit
and uh comes back in and says yes it's
me
and so they exile um the wife and her
night
and um sad thing about the wife all of
her daughters
are born without noses and all of her
daughter's daughters are born without
noses i don't think that's how
hereditary genetics work marie de france
really let herself down there the story
of biscuit that's amazing and to think
that steven spielberg made that film in
the same year as jurassic park and
schindler's list as well
the adventure you have heard actually
took place do not doubt it
is that the end that's the final line
yeah when someone ends a story
like that i immediately doubt it and
that actually happened don't say it
didn't
thank you very much for that story a
shorter wasn't it it was and
what was it about again yeah it was
um you say it you say it
b-dog that's cleverett uh
well uh we've we've best claretted the
news and now we're gonna best claret the
the wrap at the end of the show because
that's what happened so let me give you
my phone which has all of the news
i hope you're going to enjoy rapping
about basketball oh my gosh
um here we go time for the rap about
some of the things we've spoken about
today alice winn has the suggestions
we've got a beat that is
drop in um let's uh get that first
suggestion
accidentally saying the c word whilst on
a geek oh yes to bahrain
it's my fault can't blame my brain when
i'm early in the morning and i'm in
bahrain but virtually
the kids heard from me they're like
can't stand this absurdity
why's the guy really trying to front
why's he talking about caveman going on
the hunt but it came out with the
c-u-n-t i was red in the face
embarrassing
he still didn't matter at the end
because i called them up i said i didn't
intend to say those things didn't say
that customers said don't worry chris
yeah we trust you tinder background
checks
learning the word let me get this and
i'm looking for birds swiping to left
and the right
sadly two years ago i got into a fight
beating up a guy outside that pub now i
can't get on tinder and can't get
love all the ladies they say whoa his
fault that he got convicted for all that
assault still if i'm in the uk now i can
vote
if i travel over here by boat then you
can't do that maybe be telling cause
you're gonna get locked up yeah like a
felony what would it take for you to
change yourself
when i'm in taiwan change my name i
would say oh tell the truth for me i'm
gonna change that get that free sushi
but i need more stuff get that relief i
don't want that fish here i want that
beef
that's the type of food that i deserve i
change my name if i get the surf and
tough
s and t i can change it back unless in
taiwan you do it like thwack
five minus two you only get three times
and you've gotta make sure you make up
your
this is awesome if you're a werewolf
let's stay right away
over in france that's slightly in spain
nobody can pronounce his name
excuse me how hard can it get hello my
name is best cleverer
wanna spell that wanna say it for sure
can you pronounce that on a register
a best clover you can call me b tiny
little werewolf
t he she was cruel because she left me
for another guy and the gangster looked
so sexy so they bit off my nose why
cause he stole all the werewolves
clothes
all other king took him down said you're
a bad daughter to your mother so we're
gonna give you the torture best club
best club best club best puppet best
club
best give it a rest about that because
the beast coming in there with a high
hat ah people feeling lots of pain with
a jab in the rum not getting on the
plane if you ain't got the vaccine or
that was a great rhyme i got look in my
brain i'll be stirring the pot with the
names of the cities and names of the
regions
queensland everybody needs them back the
governor you're wrong
in nebraska he's on this want to get
crazy saying you should really try it oh
beefs are part of a healthy diet
well quiet why am i talking australian
there aussie invoice
i do not care give up meat for one
single day
he'll be like jared polis nay hey i
don't like you gonna eat that cow
put it in your mouth bite down and shout
out and i want to get a lump of wax on
my fist so i punch that trump how resist
when i see that massive candle i say
here's a fist let's see if you can
handle
obviously he doesn't fight back he's a
wax work he gets a right smack with a
jab
uppercut there with a hook one more
thing that you really want to look at
the book take it from there put it in
the face
oh yeah it's a shame no babies by 45
if you thought you'd have one then it
won't arrive why because you go not
shrunk to the size of a peanut
yeah so to my surprise whatever
you seem very unprepared for that more i
just i thought i thought you would talk
longer about uh
the trump punching oh sorry wow trump
punch is a good
good name isn't it for like an important
knight who turns to a werewolf yeah
trump punch trump puncher
yeah and so then if you had a girl you
have to call it trump patina yeah
exactly
um that is the end of the show we didn't
go visit by colonel whitachens at all
very sad i feel like he's really just
let us down he's moved on
he has moved on alice if people want to
move on from this podcast and find you
online where should they go uh they can
go to instagram or they'll find me at
let them ebooks with underscores instead
of spaces
lovely stuff and they can find me uh on
youtube and on instagram search chris
turner comedy i'll come up about all
that
um and yeah come to a zoom gig sign up
at the link in the description
cannot wait to see you there it's been a
pleasure all my
love uh from chris i love you all
i love you all and i feel a dignified
and normal
amount of affection for you you always
have you want to mention the war a third
time
goodbye